hey guys today is the 18th of January
and my name is just an you're watching
games bunnies mario kart 64 is coming to
the wii's virtual console this thursday
in europe sorry North American Mario
fans but for the moment and this one has
only been announced for your friends
across the pond however it is already
available through the original wii's
virtual console Eurogamer has reported
that the game will cost 899 euro mario
kart 64 on wii u supports up to four
players and features all the courses you
sucked at as a kid which you're probably
much better at now so pick it up on
Thursday if you're keen to play it again
Microsoft has pulled the old create news
by revealing plans to announce actual
news thing today by saying that next
week and they'll be talking about the
xbox one system update replying to a
tweet from a fan requesting info on
what's next on the Xbox one preview
program Microsoft's director of program
management Mikey bara replied pay
attention next week Xbox one updates are
generally revealed first to preview
program members before they go live
publicly aside from a minor
behind-the-scenes update that landed in
early January the console hasn't
received a new system update since
November's new Xbox one experience
microsoft said they intentionally held
back on releasing any further patches
over the holiday season as they wanted
to focus on stability the next major
update for xbox one is due in February's
the divisions associate creative
director Julian Garrity has explained
why the multiplayer RPG shooter will not
three including player trading at launch
Garrity explained to GamesRadar it's the
reality of production some features make
it some features don't adding that the
decision came down to a priority of
different features he also mentioned
that player trading may make an
appearance in the future as the game is
constantly evolving and people are
clearly passionate about the addition as
divisions world warcraft has had a
trading system for many years while
destiny may
reduce it at some point in the future
let me know down in the comments section
how you feel about player trading
systems in games be sure to head the
games but we've got stories on dining
like enhanced edition and the witness
coming to Xbox one that is everything
that I have for you today as always let
me know what you thought of today's
stories and I will catch you again
tomorrow